we are here with Gerard Butler action
star rom-com cutie and overall just
funnest dopest coolest human
um I was wondering if you would play my
favorite game with me it's called behind
the scenes first thing that comes to
your mind or a naughty detail or a fly
on the wall moment I don't know anything
that might you know be fun to hear let's
kick it off with the Ugly Truth
maybe one of the funnest scenes I've
ever done in a movie because she's
supposed to obviously have something
stuck inside her she's basically having
an orgasm during the scene
um because this and and just keeps
playing with the controls uh so she had
to make the speech whilst the whilst you
know and she was so good and it was one
of those ones where I could just sit
back and enjoy a hilarious brilliant
performance I love her and you're right
she also vomits really well if you've
seen knocked up and she has that scene
where she's like trying to talk and
she's she is brilliant oh she's
phenomenal she's good but this scene
that was I think her best part of the
she was great in the whole movie but
that scene I literally was in the moment
but also like wow she's amazing she is
amazing
um 300.
okay let me focus on this man because
Zack Snyder won he's I think such a
talented director he's also one of those
guys he's just good at everything and
you know that final scene when when I
throw the spear
um towards Xerxes
and the kids he's like this is not you
know it's hard with the camera angle to
get and he's like I want you to hit uh
right up there on that Mark and the Mark
was miles away you know it's not easy
it's like so he's like okay and he's so
nice so he goes okay well just let me
and he takes the spear and he throws it
and it goes about 50 yards goes through
the curtain with the X on it right
through the X it was like the perfect
spear throw and I'm standing there
feeling like a complete idiot okay so
that that's what you want me to do okay
okay when you're walking around in like
a leather loin clothy leather stroppy
diaper thing like eventually like in day
one are you like okay
okay okay okay and then by day like 150
you're just like okay that's that's
exactly what happened the first day I
walked out like that and you walked past
because not everybody in the movie is
involved in the filming process you know
those electricians there's people look
and there's all the we were in in
Montreal so there's all these big
quebecers big guys eating sandwiches and
they turn around and I'm literally like
you know walking out and they're like
like what the hell is this I thought I
can't do this how am I going to be like
this for three months and then yeah then
the next minute you're like come on guys
okay
okay The Phantom of the Opera
it's a role that I
you know that character is such beauty
and talent and and to him and then such
a sadness and a loneliness and weirdly I
went into that space in that movie I was
constantly grateful for just where I was
and and the opportunity I'd been given
but I so went into that role it was like
I felt all his pain I loved it I loved
being in the music and being on the sets
and being but I remember thinking wow I
feel like I'm really taking his journey
now you know so a lot of the time I'd be
I got very sad during during that movie
it was a beautiful experience and and a
sad heart because it just made me feel
like for everybody in life you know the
pain that people go through and they
want something so much and they and they
can't have it especially with love you
know but with everything
um to to know that that's just either
not possible or so far away because it
reminded me as a kid when my dream was
to be an actor and I began I was in
Scotland and it was all I wanted to do
was make these Fantastical movies
um and then I thought but you're from
Scotland you're looking yeah what chance
have you got you know so that kind of
heartbreak and um but especially with
love so I found myself in that that
space a lot and it was actually lovely
it was very cathartic now that is one
emotional eloquent answer thank you
thank you thank you
it's not a fun one but it's a meaningful
one yeah but you're such a good
Storyteller like you really are you have
a beginning middle and end an arc like
it's so I'm like it takes a bit long but
you get there don't tell me about
long-winded please I could use an editor
for life okay the Bounty Hunter I love
them Jennifer an
IST okay just it's just a general
experience she is the coolest chick on
the planet it's so great to work with
fun down to earth humble and um and it
was such a joy just playing these
playing these scenes with her you know
because that's a fun movie right but you
needed to if somebody was going to play
games it wasn't gonna you know who was
in it and and and that's what what we
did and she just brought me on it was so
this gracious and cool and such a fun
you know and I'm thinking
worked up with Jennifer Aniston this is
amazing uh and she I just had a blast
making that movie if you guys haven't
seen this you check it out I am so in
love with her
it's my bones right I just I'm a like
Jennifer Aniston I just everything she
does I love her I I think she is for who
I've worked with the coolest woman in
the business you know just she's just
awesome she is kind of what your fantasy
of her would be like she's fun she's
cool she's the real yeah she's the real
deal yeah absolutely well you know who
else I absolutely love and who is
literally pregnant with twins right now
and I couldn't think higher of this
individual
um and this film P.S I Love You Hilary
Swain
welcome to mind in this movie I remember
saying to the director I'm not going to
think about myself in this movie I'm
only going to think about her make sure
she's okay she's cool because that's
kind of who this guy was I'm going to
tell you it made the experience so much
more fun when I got out of my own head
actor self-obsessed how am I doing I
actually was more like how's she doing
and she's so cool and so great to work
with that I almost killed her you know
you know the scene where where I'm
dancing and I have the what do you call
them suspenders and I literally shot
that scene for a day and a half and I
had to dance like an idiot and the
suspenders and I'm like it was like that
first moment in 300 I can't believe I'm
doing this this dance in my box of
shorts and then at one point she's
I I the the the clip which was a
crocodile clip got stuck in the
television as I'm crawling towards her
and she's right in front of me and she's
laughing hysterically this thing they
had the camera people had um these uh
plastic fronts to protect themselves
from this crocodile it was so dangerous
and because I had to Ping it and it
would go past my face and this time I'm
crawling Towards the bed it gets stuck
it it released boom flies over my head
hits her in the head slashes her head I
mean I cut her up you could even see the
teeth of the uh she has to get taken to
hospital every literally imagine this
studio and in three seconds everybody's
gone and I'm just sitting there in my in
my Irish tummy box of shorts and and my
boots and a pair of socks and I just
started crying I was like
she's off to the hospital there's nobody
on set I was like oh my God talk about
imposter syndrome you're like I should
be on this movie I don't deserve it that
was like yeah see I knew this was gonna
happen because you got in touch with
your sensitive side and you just said
like every woman's fantasy like I
decided to put her needs and thoughts
and wants first we're all like mm-hmm
yeah tell me more that was the last time
that happened
to Gerard Butler you are everything that
we want you to be as we fantasize about
hanging out with Jennifer Aniston and
she's going to fulfill that fantasy so
do you thank you thank you so much thank
you everybody
[Applause]
[Music]